henry ruggs could find himself behind
bars again after missing a breath test
his lawyers are also trying to question
the fire department's response to that
fiery crash that killed tina tintor and
her dog after rugs slammed into them
going over 150 miles per hour moments
before the crash victoria saha live in
studio with a look at his bail
conditions and how the breath test
device works victoria hey brian when
rugs was first released on bail there
were strict orders from the judge that
he cannot miss a single one of his
breath tests turns out he did
no alcohol no drugs and no driving are
rules rugs cannot break if he wants to
stay out of jail court documents say
ruggs has to test for alcohol four times
a day using a handheld device his
attorney david chestnut says it hasn't
always worked failing once to alert
ruggs to take the test he's been dutiful
completely
he also self-hesitated
shortly after the missed test however
the judge was notified ruggs waited 36
minutes to take the test we reached out
to the maker of the device scram the
company says it's rare for a device to
not alert a person chestnut also asked
the judge to subpoena the clark county
fire department for their records
related to the crash in a motion
chestnut claims the department waited 20
minutes before they started to
extinguish the carr fire the clark
county fire department has continuously
said they did their best considering the
intensity of the scene
they've got to
hear the tones go off get in the unit
and then travel time
so
everything i've heard is that
the fire was almost instantaneous
bystanders tried to help and then the
fire it got too much where they where
they couldn't continue to try and help
by missing his breath test he did
violate his terms of his bill he will be
facing the judge monday morning to
explain himself denise